What are your thoughts on nicotine and its effect on cancer?
Regarding cancer in inferensonis, can I go to a local tanning facility that offers inferensonis or do I need to go elsewhere?
Your input is appreciated.
So this one, yeah, you can go to a local tanning facility that offers inferensonis. That's just fine. I don't see any problem with that.
You know, there's not toxins or anything that you're going to pick up at a local tanning facility doing a sauna, so I don't see any issue with that.
This I think is a completely separate question, nicotine, and its effect on cancer.
Well, at first glance, I mean nicotine, you know, is a major cause of lung cancer. That's still the number, I think it's the number one deadly cancer is a small cell lung cancer.
But in truth, it's more probably the chemicals that they put in tobacco and not necessarily the nicotine.
They put addictive forming chemicals in tobacco. So tobacco today is very different than tobacco, maybe back in the 1800s.
So tobacco is screened with the addictive for addiction, forming chemicals in order to get people to be addicted to it to continue to buy their tobacco.
That is probably the most carcinogen aspect of tobacco.
So, but in truth, nicotine is still probably should be considered a toxic substance.
You don't think it should be consumed. People will say, well, tobacco is just a natural substance. I mean, it's God made it.
But I don't think we're supposed to smoke it. Just because God made it doesn't mean we're supposed to smoke it just because God made rocks doesn't mean we're supposed to eat them.
You know, so you can't use that excuse with something that's consumed.
So, you know, I don't know if your question really has to do a second head smoke.
And it's affected our sarcoma. I don't know if any studies are that. I would definitely say that nicotine is a toxin. It isn't good for anybody.
So, but if it's, you're dealing with second head smoke, you're dealing with a lot more toxins than just a nicotine that's in that smoke.
So, it's highly toxic substance.